you're new here aren't you
I'm Audrey you never thought of yourself
as mean Oh give us a break Audrey we
love you and all but we're not about to
make you out as the victim more sparkles
sure mouse stole the future king of
auradon right out of your manicured
hands but she's the queen that auradon
deserves you would abuse your power and
continue being rude and condescending to
the entire kingdom we know you've got a
big heart deep down but would it kill
you to show it every once in a while
don't worry Audrey you won't be queen
but you'll still have status if it
weren't for Hades Audrey might never
have woken up from her deep slumber keep
watching to find out what would have
happened to Audrey of Hades never agreed
to help her out Audrey may be the
daughter of the sweet and innocent
Princess Aurora but she's nothing like
her mother instead she's like the
vindictive grandmother who raised her
clean Leah Audrey was groomed for the
throne ever since she was a little girl
so when I certain purple-haired v-k took
King Ben and the future he could offer
away from her she knew she had to
retaliate
Audrey planned on stealing the Queen's
crown from the museum but Maleficent
sceptre sensed her evil intentions and
came knocking despite not wanting to
hurt anyone Audrey gave in to evil and
nearly brought the kingdom aboard on to
its knees but instead of being sent to
the Isle of the Lost like the other
villains Audrey was instantly pardoned
by King Ben and his future Queen Ben and
mal even went as far as to apologize to
Audrey for their actions that never gave
Audrey any closure after leaving her for
mal and mal never apologized for
cheating her way into Ben's heart thanks
to Mouse dad Hades Audrey woke up in the
safety of her own bed but that solution
was much too easy here's what really
should have happened to Audrey at the
end of descendants three as we all know
the royal guards retrieved Hades from
the Isle because they needed him to wake
up Audrey with his ember after being
knocked out by the Emperor Audrey
appeared to be a lost cause but Hades
agreed to revive her for free
he wasn't offered a reduced sentence
better living conditions or any perks at
all instead Hades was asked for a favor
and given nothing in return well that
doesn't seem like Hades at all so what
if Hades attempt to revive Audrey had
been unsuccessful what would have
happened then well we're guessing that
waking Sleeping Beauty jr. would have
become a job for true love's kiss
but since Ben isn't in love with Audrey
and Audrey isn't in love with Chad who
would wake the princess up this
alternate ending would have confirmed
that then inaud reword never made to
last mal would definitely try everything
to wake Audrey up so she would ask Ben
to try but since mal is his true love
Audrey wouldn't move a muscle then next
up would be Chad but as previously
mentioned Audrey sort of hates Chad so
that wouldn't work either as it turns
out Audrey would have to kiss a mirror
to break the spell
after all she seems to be the only one
in love with herself but all jokes aside
Audrey is lucky that Hades chose to
revive her because well she probably
would have been stuck like that for
quite a while it's hard for people to
qualify for true love's kiss when they
don't have a kind bone in their body we
all know that Audrey is the queen of
mean whether she wants to accept the
title or not she was raised to be rude
selfish and entitled which is probably
why she wasn't invited to Jane's
birthday but deep down audrey has a big
heart just like everyone else and she's
bound to start using it at some point or
another most parents make it a point to
raise sweet and sensible children but
when you think about it Audrey's parents
are nowhere to be found
despite their daughter being on the
verge of never waking up again the only
family member by Audrey's bedside is her
grandmother Queen Leah and we all know
what a peach she is if it hadn't been
for Hades Audrey probably would have
never woken up instead of sending Audrey
to the Isle for her crimes King been
pardoned her but that just doesn't make
any sense
sure Audrey never planned on stealing
Maleficent scepter and destroying
auradon but she did plan on stay
the Queen's crown from the museum which
is still an offense last time we checked
if Audrey had never resorted to theft
she would not become the villain of
descendants three Audrey most definitely
deserved to get punished for her crimes
while we don't agree with her being sent
to the Isle for life some community
service would have been nice we can just
imagine Audrey wearing a pink jumpsuit
while cleaning trash off the highway
Audrey should have received some
mandatory goodness classes at the very
least despite her many shortcomings
Audrey knows how to get things done she
has all the necessary qualities to
become a public figure which is why we
wouldn't be surprised if Audrey one day
runs for president
sure Ben and mal will rule over auradon
but that wouldn't stop Audrey from
trying to make a political move and if
that doesn't work maybe one day after
fairy godmother retires Audrey will
become the new headmistress of auradon
prep who do you think is Audrey's true
love and why sound off in the comments
and that's a wrap give this video a big
thumbs up and don't forget to subscribe
to the things will catch you next time
[Music]